[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we sift
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today
we're talking about freedom and
fantasticity a key theme and
existentialist philosophy so we're going
to be getting into some John Paul sart
and so
some other Frenchies I think as well
this is something that that I I got into
quite a bit in college so I've been
thinking about this for quite some time
and I was very interested when you
propose that we we talk about this so
what is your particular interest what's
peaking your curiosity about these kind
of metaphysical questions
I'm very interested in like meaning and
the power that meaning has and gives to
an individual
and the places in which people find that
meaning and unfortunately there are many
pitfalls where people try to find
meaning and and they can they can find a
facsimile of it but they're not actually
thinking about why they actually accept
that and so I guess to a certain extent
you can see this in
um
uh say like uh
far right wing groups like skinheads or
whatnot or also like
um fundamentalists of any religious
stripe
um that they have an idea of they know
exactly what is true
um like true true absolutely but that
can also lead to some really incredibly
negative violent ends and I want to I'm
very interested in
uh the existentialists especially sart
and Simone de Bolivar about how they try
to thread this needle figuring out where
one should actually be uh placing that
meaning
that makes a lot of sense and actually
when you when you talk about it that way
in terms of meaning
I guess one of the good launching points
for this is
I would say that when it comes to groups
like that or or really anybody who buys
into something that is providing them
with with certainty it's not just that
they think that now they've got the map
to the universe and they can tell who
the good people are and the bad people
are and what history is all about and
you know how they're on the right side
of it or anything along those lines it's
also self-definition it's also figuring
out who they are and what their story is
and how they fit into all of this and
certain to before that I I myself I
would actually say that maybe they go a
little bit too far
in the loosey-goosiness of of how much
is up to us you know but I think that
they are very useful in breaking down
those those like hardened blocks of well
this is the way it has to be and it
could be stuff like you were talking
about where it's one form of religious
fundamentalism around other and we're
seeing this as a big problem you know in
the in the world uh not just here in
America but on the world scene
um and not just with right-wing uh
groups that have you know
increasingly public presence and uh
some really
um quite amazingly stretched out
narratives about things but I think you
could also talk about this as people who
like buy into
um
let's call it simplistic understandings
of the American way of life or the
American dream or you know actually I'll
tell you a story about about somebody
who I saw
and I won't say who it is although I'll
just say it's somebody who's close to me
this this guy was the you know if he was
in the 50s he would have been the guy
wearing the uh the gray flannel suit you
know he fit into the the University
where he was working as a advisor for
students which is a good job right it's
it's nice you're helping people out
you're you're guiding them along
um it's definitely comfortable yeah and
and he ended up you know he was very
diligent and he had the view that well
if you just do your work right and treat
everybody nice and fit in good things
are going to happen to you and that's
that's a rather simplistic narrative and
sometimes things work that way and a lot
of times things don't and he had that
way of looking at the whole world so he
would give me advice you know about how
I should be more optimistic and you know
not criticize systems because you know
that way everything would work out
nicely for me too and he would tell me
to all sorts of other people which made
him a little insufferable you know
um even despite the niceness and what
ended up happening is because he was so
good at what he did he started rising up
through the the ranks and eventually he
uh when when the dean of advising left
at his university he was tapped to be
the acting Dean and he he always had
dreams of becoming a
University president someday that's like
his big goal in life you know we have
all sorts of other goals that would
never be something that I would find
meaning in right but that was I don't
know where he got that from but that was
what he wanted to do and so this is like
a you know stepping stone and then
catastrophe hit he
um was invited to apply for the position
when it became open and they ended up
hiring a less qualified outside
candidate even though he'd been doing
the job for a year
and now his whole world fell apart
because he was he was resting everything
on this one basic principle which is
that life is fair and I guess there's
two basic principles life is fair and if
you put in good work you're going to be
recognized and you know the universe is
going to reward you or people are gay
fell into that just World fallacy right
there exactly yeah and so and I'll I'll
let you guess what do you think happened
to this guy
uh he
a psychological break or just
maybe just some pretty deep depression
well you didn't get depressed but there
was a psychological break not not like a
psychotic break or anything like that
what do you what do you think he did
uh did he become a nihilist
kinda more more of a hedonist more of a
um you know the system is rigged
everything is is wrong so I'm going to
enjoy myself as much as possible he
really went off the deep end he like
swung from one extreme of being the
buttoned up uh you know essentially
corporate type right and when I say
corporate type I'm not knocking people
in corporations there's lots of cool
people in corporations but there's a
corporate type right that we know so he
swings all the way to the other end and
becomes a bad boy and he and his
um you know he it broke up his marriage
although his marriage was pretty
you know it was the kind of marriage
where you'd look at them and you say I
can't imagine those people ever having
intimacy
um and so they had a uh you know they
liked each other very much and and then
he he found you know
um you know are you saying that his uh
marriage there living in bad faith to
have him yeah I think so insofar as a
marriage generally is understood as
involving what we you know in the old
days they called conjugal love right
attraction sexual desire and enjoyment
and that sort of thing I mean otherwise
just be roommates or friends or
something like that which they remained
by the way their friends after the
divorce but he swung the other way and
now he's partying and he goes to a
different place and he you know he's not
going to get like the who's on He's Not
Gonna Get Fooled Again right and
eventually he came back to the middle
and you know now he's I think probably
not just older and wiser but a bit more
grounded and I think that to go back to
this issue of meaning he's he's now
established some sort of stable meaning
for himself in relation to his his his
current wife and his job and all of that
sort of stuff but I think a lot of
people you know when when things are
working out for them they they
they decide that I'm going to invest
myself in this way of of being and
things staying the same here and then
when it falls apart because I mean one
of the things that start in De bouvoir
tell us is so much of our life is really
contingent
and I don't think you or I probably had
any trouble figuring that out but I
think there's quite a few people who for
a while things work out for them and
then there come these these crises and
we call existential crisis crises of
meaning right so yeah
that's a long story but it was good
though it's very illustrative of this
point and you know maybe it goes to one
of the central topics of existentialism
that existence precedes essence and so
he it seems like he had this uh
essentialist idea that he had a there is
an essence of like a just world and he
was playing his part within that world
and he should be rewarded for him
playing his part well
and all of a sudden on this the
grounding for his meaning of this you
know this Essence that was out there in
The Ether was torn away from him that it
doesn't comport to reality yeah that's
the thing it was revealed that reality
was not what he had thought it was right
right
um he he might say oh you know
um my meaning has been taken away and
and maybe you know we have to be kind of
careful about where we place our meeting
maybe that's that's part of the uh
lesson there
right and uh I've made the argument in
the past that you should place your
meaning in some place that cannot be
taken away from you ah so you're
bringing in the stoics right at that
point yes it was a a paper I wrote uh on
what the place where you should place
your meaning is I don't think the
The Stokes talk exactly in those terms
um but to place the the seats your
Locust of your meaning in something that
can't be taken away from you so for
example if you you place your meaning in
your job which a lot of people tend to
do yeah but your job is a very ephemeral
position you either lose it or your
company could fold or you know a number
of different things could come about and
then now you're not that thing anymore
and if you move your your place to
something that is more abstract so say
you're
um you're an educator instead of a
teacher at Marquette University for
example and and now you uh you can allow
yourself with the idea of your meaning
be an educator that you can now uh put
the uh the tangible position of where
you put
educator into many different places and
so it doesn't even have to be at a
university as long as you're teaching or
passing information oh you're changing
the meaning you're widening the meaning
of educator in that case right from
something that you've defined it as you
know this is really an interesting point
because as somebody who has worked in a
lot of different places in Academia and
right now I I routinely teach for three
different places and I still have my
Marquette email so I always know what's
going on there as well so you can say
I'm tapped into four
um it's really amazing to me when I deal
with people who've only really worked at
one place or I've worked at one place
for quite a long time and had worked in
another place you know they had sort of
a serial career rather than a uh more
Smorgasbord career let's call it
they they lack a frame of reference
quite often they think that the way
things are done there is just the way
things are you know and I think that's
kind of a natural tendency not just in
you know academic institutions but
workplaces if you've been with one place
for a very long time or you've got a set
of clients and you just always deal with
them it's kind of natural to think well
that's that's just how everything works
right right and you know to for example
in education especially in colleges you
have that 10-year track and you think
that's that's the way it has to be and
if you get thrown off of that are you
talking about the way it has to be like
in terms of like
for for an individual are you talking
about like well that's that's how
um college should be organized no as in
like the gold standard of an individual
being a teacher and it's like oh you
know you're given this idea of like you
want to get tenure maybe it's changing
because the whole College University
Systems are changing but for a very very
long time it's like that was like the
only way that you could signify that you
had made it yeah as an educator you had
one goal and
um and I guess to go back to my ideas to
like you know do you know what you are
is a very
you're still educating and it's it's
making this a uh bringing abstraction
instead of a specific example of that
larger category you you say like well my
goal is to educate and I can do that in
many many places with many different uh
people and in different uh
ways and
um as long as you keep it General enough
then there are you know a whole host of
places in which you can express that uh
General meaning you know that's a really
interesting
topic and if you don't mind me going off
off our main topic a little bit sure um
so you know we have right now a lot of
graduate students in different fields
and there definitely are not the jobs
for them you know most of them that get
phds are are not going to work as
professors in their fields that's just
that's not feasible it has an infeasible
since my generation where when I would
apply for a job they were you know
anywhere from 300 to 500 other people
applying for that same single job
now granted you know we were all
applying for different jobs so it would
cut it down a bit but it would still be
way more people than than you could find
jobs for
so
you know it's prudent for younger you
know 20-something graduate students to
think about alternative careers and it
turns out that if you get a degree in
the humanities and actually if you get a
degree in other things the social
sciences the Natural Sciences well you
know you can actually do a lot of other
things you've shown that you can carry
out research you can synthesize
information you probably can make decent
arguments there's there's lots of things
that one could do now here's where it
gets really interesting I know of a few
universities where they resisted
bringing in people to talk with their
graduate students about that because
they didn't want The Graduate students
to get the wrong idea the wrong idea
would be that you shouldn't just aim for
a tenure track job
instead you know you should you should
apply yourself to that and try to get a
postdoc somewhere and just chase this
will of the Wisp wherever it leads you
and be willing to sacrifice everything
for that because to consider an
alternative career path is to sell out
to give up
settle for something now you know it
when when those professors were applying
for jobs maybe that actually made some
sense if they're like 60 years old and
close to retiring they are from a
generation where there are sometimes
more jobs than there were applicants and
people would actually call you up and
say hey can you come out here to this
University and start teaching for us
that has has been gone for you know 30
years and to tell now here we come back
to the thing about meaning right how do
we Define the meaning of our existence
you're you're on to something really
important here
if if you're if your desire if your
drive is to be an educator and I think
for a lot of these people who are in The
Graduate School tracks they they really
do want to teach people and and so does
so many other people it's it's a a
natural human drive that's that some of
us have more strongly than others
um
well you know do you allow your
professors to Define this for you what
it means to be an educator they probably
have no idea what the world you're going
into looks like or do you take your cues
from
things that are closer to the ground and
say I need to be realistic about what it
means to be an educator it might mean
being a docent in a museum it might mean
um organizing things in in you know for
political rallies it might mean all
sorts of other possibilities
and when you look especially like what
you do with Sophia or anyone that wants
to do public philosophy and I guess
we're just yeah I constrained the the
topic to the the topic of teaching and
utilizing philosophy okay
um there are a number of places in which
you can be materially a benefit to
people there are very large companies
that have very large power in this
country at this point in time and uh
there is a room for uh ethicists to be
in those positions because you know they
are making decisions that are affecting
you know hundreds of millions if not
billions of people and there are ways
that you can utilize these skills
um in really beneficial ways for
Humanity I guess it's true teaching is
just you know benefiting the New
Generation
Um there there's definitely a corollary
there that's yeah actually that's
another important Point oftentimes we
lose sight of what's the point of
teaching well it's you know if we think
about things in a very Grand scale what
what separates us from the animals it
doesn't just having technology or being
able to speak to each other stuff like
that it's human culture and human
culture is something that has to be
relearned basically every 15 years
because you have a new generation coming
up who doesn't know anything
unless we teach it to them and and I
mean they'll figure some things out on
their own like how to how to enjoy
sexually and how to get drunk and you
know things like that those and how to
compete with each other those are kind
of I won't say no-brainers because they
are complicated too but when it comes to
the stuff that we really need to be
passing on to them
um unless we make a concerted effort to
do it it's just not going to happen this
this view that like now we're in this
technology age and information is just
floating out there I have a lot of
students who don't know how to use
Wikipedia well you know or Google for
that matter you know they take the stuff
that's on the very first page and they
never go any further than that you know
so somebody has to I mean we could we
could complain about oh these these kids
these days you know but the better thing
is to actually like show them
other possibilities
you know what they're missing out on
right and so for example we're talking
about start and whatnot
um today and we think there's a
important topic to talk about yeah and
why are you always
potentially hear about this is at a
university philosophy course then this
is going to eventually uh you know seep
back into the ether
yeah why are we talking about these
people that have been dead since the 80s
you know uh right we're old back that uh
well because it's perennial and it's
it's got stuff to say to the the younger
generation as well as those of us I
won't speak for you Dan but those of us
who are in middle age
so so let's talk about sergeant and okay
um
so I guess we should talk about
um Factory and Transcendence here yeah
so these are jargony terms we've got to
provide if not a definition of these
some sort of characterization so what do
you take fantasticity to me that's a
cool sounding term right yeah I've got
my Factory
yeah it's it's fairly simple it's just
like the
the concrete realities of an individual
um their physical attributes and their
uh
their history their uh what they did
what happened to them
um so as well as like their habits the
dresses and their like expected
responses as an individual at this
moment of time and so these things
change over time as we gain new
experiences and new skills but yeah it
is it is a a thing to try to think about
at a particular moment in time for an
individual
some of our Factory changes but some of
it we can't escape from like so for our
in our society for example
uh we have racial categories and the
race that you are categorized under is
part of your factory and that as we know
determines a lot of other things you
know because we we still do have people
who respond to others primarily on the
basis of oftentimes perceived race you
know
um and I suppose we could say gender
fits in there and now now we inhabit a
time where the the notion of gender is
becoming more fluid but you know it's
it's mostly pretty fixed right and
there's there's vast parts of our
society where uh you might try to say
well I'm gendered this way and then
people say nope you're getting this and
that would be Again part of your factory
as well so so something and here's like
you know I'm I'm not super tall and so
yeah yeah so I don't have the the
physical abilities that like for example
Usain Bolt has so I'm never going to be
a world champion Sprinter well you and
me both you know I'm tall but I'm not
going to do that either
one
just like regardless of how much I train
that's just not in my factory that's an
outcome that could happen yeah and so
that's actually a good good
point to talk about right we can we can
change some of the aspects of our
Factory but
um you know some of it we're just stuck
with and it's kind of contingent and we
didn't choose it but that's the way it
is right and so I think some people view
themselves as essentially just all
Factory I'm just what people have made
me or I'm just
um what I chose to be at one point in
time and now I'm stuck with that right
right it's like my dad was an
electrician and his dad was electrician
and I'm gonna be an electrician because
that's just the way it is yeah you could
have the opposite thing too where you'd
be like my dad was an electrician but I
wasn't going to listen to what the man
told me so I went out and became a rebel
and you know uh became a plumber
[Laughter]
but it could still become an electrician
later on in life well I guess maybe dad
had something to say but I think there's
there's quite a few people who and this
is one very practical application of
this who they they commit themselves to
something and they get themselves sort
of mindset fixed in it or stuck in it
and they think I can't do otherwise and
it could also be in relationships people
are like well I married this person or
I'm dating this person guess I'm stuck
with them or or it could be a type like
well I guess I always got to you know I
always got to date people who treat me
this way
this is you know definitely a sun cost
fallacy in that like
yeah see that's a great example uh the
sun cost fallacy is this idea that I've
already spent so much money on something
and so I should keep on spending money
on this and to maintain it because I've
already put already this money in so
it's kind of like uh for example uh if
you got a stock and you you spend so
much money on it and it keeps on going
down you're like well I can't sell now
yeah
um even though it might like they might
go bankrupt and you'll lose all of your
money and so the idea to try to get
yourself out of the sun cost LLC is to
say especially for like monetary things
is to say
um if I was going to invest in this
thing now would I invest in it at this
point with you know disregard my history
that
that what I have with it and so this
kind of comes through into the idea of
transcendence and this is our our
freedom for the possibilities of things
yet to come
yeah and and now notice like cert when
he talks about this he talks about it in
in terms that seem very negative right
our Transcendence
for for the possibilities those
possibilities don't exist they're just
like imagined or you know they're
they're not like floating out there for
us to grab them like low-hanging fruit
or something we have to act to make them
to to make them live possibilities and
then to transform them from
possibilities to actualities and there's
no guarantee in the world that we
inhabit that are deciding to do that
will actually make them into actual so
if I I don't know let's say I decide as
I've tried to make myself do a couple
times you know when I was in
undergraduate I started learning Chinese
and I was tutoring Chinese students and
hanging out with them so I actually
learned quite a bit but learning
Mandarin you know and I didn't keep up
with it and then I always go through
these surges where I'm like this is
going to be the year I'm finally gonna
like buckle down and start on the path
to learning Mandarin yeah one of the
world's largest languages right and got
a great literature to it uh it wouldn't
be a bad thing for me to do now every
time that I do that I I really have to
blame it on myself off I I haven't stuck
with it I get tied up with other
projects but let's say I actually do you
know let's say 2021 is the year and I
make an effort and I like get all the
language books and all the AIDS and
stuff like that and then it turns out
that I don't know the internet crashes
and it's gone uh well you know maybe I
don't learn Mandarin again and it's not
up to me
um there's things that can interfere
with with those possibilities but that
would be the basis of your practicity
that you no longer have the resources to
get at that yeah and not just my factory
but everyone else's too right yeah I
guess you could still say like well you
could just you know plug away into China
or something and immerse yourself there
yeah I suppose that's I mean
I have responsibilities so I don't know
that I could actually pull that off
that's that's a good example so yeah
this you know we are beings who have uh
no matter how how much our our current
situation is restricted we do have some
degree of freedom to choose things for
ourselves to choose how we view things
to choose what kind of person we want to
strive to be you know and it may not be
effective but we we have some Freedom so
that's what what start calls
Transcendence
um and so there's we're constantly
living in a a push and pull between
Transcendence and practicity that our
Transcendence our choices based upon our
current state of affairs uh creates a
new Factory which and then in turn
creates a new set of potential outcomes
and choices which are a new
Transcendence yeah so
there's I guess there's two things you
can say about that one is that we're
always sort of like coming out of
Factory and then we we can't like stay
up and out of it we have to go back into
it
um sart talks about this in terms of
freedom and determinism that we're
always emerging from a determinism
exercise and some freedom and then
coming back into it which changes the
determinism a bit and allows us to have
a coherent World
um but there's a tendency for people to
to want to be on on one side or the
other let's say I have one level or the
other since I'm used vertical metaphor
they some people want to say I'm just in
the factory I can't change anything this
is just the way it is
but they're exercising their freedom
according to start and then there's
other people who want to like just stay
in the Freedom by itself
but freedom is sort of like um you know
sort of like a
certain kinds of dishes or drinks it
could stale real quick you can't like
keep Freedom bottled up and not use it
it's kind of use it or lose it right so
yeah it's got a shelf life and so this
you know he she calls this if you either
choose to try to deny one or the other
living in bad faith yeah now what when
that when you hear that word what does
that bring to mind for you do you think
it has the same sort of Effectiveness as
when heed shows it back then in French
it's more viswa and then we translate it
as bad faith what do you think about
when you hear the word bad face so first
it kind of like it makes you think of
good faith and what what good faith in
our normal parlance means and like you
know someone you know is is being honest
with you that they're they're not uh
taking you for a sucker to a certain
extent yeah you know
um and so in that idea uh starters is
making the assertion that these people
that are leaving in either pure
Transcendence or pure uh facticity are
basically
uh taking themselves as suckers that
they are yeah uh removing from
themselves their own freedom and so he
there's a
way of thinking about this of you've got
either two people you've got a king that
says You must be on a stable boy or
otherwise I will kill you
or you have a story that you says like
oh my my dad owns Livery and I have to
be a stable boy until he dies and then I
might become uh the owner of the Livery
um but you still have the freedom to to
choose to not be the stable boy but
you've given yourself this story this
facticity that this is your expected
thing in life and that you are the one
that is actually being the Tyrant to
yourself and not the king you know it's
interesting that you use that word story
because
um sart was a teller of stories right he
he was one so is
um they they both wrote plays he wrote
quite a few she wrote one they wrote
novels they both wrote a lot of novels
they wrote short stories they wrote
Memoirs all sorts of things and these
are all narratives about who people are
and how they Define themselves a lot of
their stories are stories of conflict as
well where people are like trying to
impose you know this is the story for us
on to the other person and the other
person you know accepts it or rejects it
or you know whatever else is going on
um
himself didn't seem to have an awful lot
of faith in narratives and maybe part of
it is because
you know he thought that we need to have
a story that we like revise as we're
going through it and we have to take
account for that whereas a lot of people
would rather they love people love
stories I mean that's why Netflix is
such a success and and and so many other
things
um and that's the way that we understand
a lot of Concepts in our world yeah and
there's this tendency to take stories as
if they are kind of magical they reveal
how things are to us and they allow us
to get a grips on the world and
ourselves and others and all it is the
reason why parables are so powerful yeah
you're right yeah
um and so so you know maybe we have to
be really leery about the stories that
we're telling ourselves or we have to
examine them every so often
and so this is uh
kind of that
living in ambiguity the the the to be
constantly revising and and constantly
looking at your practicity and your
choices and making decisions uh requires
you to constantly be changing that story
about yourself to constantly adding in
those new information not only from
yourself but from your environment
especially the people around you because
a lot of times that we have a very
difficult time understanding who we are
uh because we're blinded to who we are
yeah and and you know
sometimes we might
um
keep the story right and but but when we
do it it's not always the same story
so I like what you said about adding
something in there and also about like
maybe taking into account what other
people say I'll give you a prime example
I used to be really really stubborn when
I was younger and actually it probably
lasted well into my 30s and
um I would I would sometimes you know I
made a lot of dumb decisions at
different points and I would sometimes
ask my close relatives why didn't you
say anything to me and they'd say well I
mean we tried but you didn't listen and
then after a while we just quit trying
because what the hell's the point you
know
um and and if I had been ready to like
hear them out I I would have made
different decisions or maybe I wouldn't
I don't know but but it would be a
different story and by hearing
retrospectively what had been left out
of my perspective I get a I get a better
um narrative along the way now you know
not necessarily everything that we add
would be better if it's if it's lies you
know like if they had said well you know
we knew you were an alien uh come from
zizak or something like that and they
were bsing me and I'm like oh well that
explains everything that would not be a
particularly good story to incorporate
right so we have to be kind of selective
and that means we have responsibility to
exercise a sort of um Prudence or
diligence when it comes to that
and so living in in bad faith a lot of
people fall into it
um because it it gives them a sense of
grounding and so like it gives them a
sense of of like security right security
and so the idea of
um
living in constantly updating who you
are and your choices that are going it's
it always provides a place where you
feel like you're lacking something and
you're always searching and feeling that
lack and searching is an uncomfortable
feeling in the uh sart and Simone
um
uh both call this uh ambiguity
yeah you know and so if you look at the
examples that sard himself gave us
and so does some wonderful work too in
in ethics of ambiguity and uh The Second
Sex and some of her other uh novels
um some of them still work and some of
them might seem a little dated I've
never been really that convinced about
starts talking about the waiter who's
being too much of a waiter I don't know
what do you make of of that one that
seems like it's a example that is not
quite a contemporary example anymore
maybe at that time in Paris there was
such a cafe culture that there was
yeah the perfect waiter that was
expected I don't know I feel like going
to Bastille days here in Milwaukee they
do have that waiter uh challenge where
they have to
perform
I forgot about that yeah but that's just
for a contest that's not like let's be
like this all the time right you know
but he does have this interesting
example of the woman who's out on a date
and
um the man puts his hand on I think her
her hand or her arm and she knows that
what this is signifying is that things
are moving along and that you know
sooner or later she's either gonna have
to decide to reject his advances or to
accept them but she pretends like she
doesn't notice his hand precisely
because of that now we could we could
switch the genders we could change this
up in all sorts of different ways but
this notion of like hiding from oneself
that one is being sooner or later
confronted with
dealing with with somebody else
um I think that's that's totally
relatable
yeah it's the you're
abdicating your choice by not making a
choice and not realizing that not making
a choice is a choice in and of itself
yeah
um that's a great line right and it
shows up in in Rush
and Rush of course got it from the
existentialists
right to even to How does it go uh to
choose not to decide still to make a
choice
um yeah and I guess another example I
had was
um there are certain religious groups
that uh have a moratorium on giving
getting uh blood transfusions and they
also make sure that their children don't
give blood transfusions and this is
would be living in bad faith because
they're saying I don't have a choice my
religion says I can't do this and thus I
won't do this and uh the existentialists
would say that your choice to accept
that religion is is a choice yeah
yeah uh when somebody says
um
these are just the beliefs I I was
raised with
this is this is where I come from
um oftentimes they'll say things as well
like you can't understand my perspective
because you haven't had the experiences
that I I do
um the existentialists would would
reject that they wouldn't say that there
aren't some things to learn from
somebody else who's had different
experiences of course but
to make it the
sort of like a brick wall that says I'm
on this side you're on that side just
doesn't work for the existentialists
right so so let's talk a little bit
about why they think people lapse into
bad faith if bad faith is kind of a
deception of oneself and others why why
do it you mentioned grounding and
security we've talked a little bit about
anxiety and ambiguity
um the fact that we are free means that
we're stuck choosing and we can't pass
the buck the responsibility Buck on to
anybody else right we're accountable
even if we don't want to say that we are
and so for for a lot of people this this
produces what the existentialists call
anxiety which could manifest as what we
psychologically call anxiety but it but
it's something broader right
yeah
um
foreign
that you get when you realize the the
enormity of the choices that you have
and and you want to run away from it to
find some other reason why uh you can't
do that instead of you know facing the
actual Choice yourself yeah in in German
it's oxed right and so people talk about
angst or angst and then that got
translated as unwas in in French so
that's why some translations say anxiety
and some say anguish
um interestingly in ancient Greek
because this is not a new emotion it's
agonia the word we get Agony from right
and so there's like this whole
constellation of things that are
uncomfortable and they're uncomfortable
in a fundamental way because it doesn't
just have to do with like you know being
afraid of I don't know my water bottle
tipping over or something like that it's
it's it's broader it's it's like well am
I going to tip this water bottle over
and it's going to like hit my keyboard
and screw it up and then I'm gonna you
know be without a keyboard kind of minor
stuff but you you get the idea
um Kierkegaard has this famous thing
about the guy who's on the edge of the
cliff and sart brings this up I don't I
don't know you tell me if this has ever
happened to you because it's happened to
me you get to the edge of the cliff and
you look down and you feel this sense of
vertigo and the sense of vertigo isn't
just like oh that's a long ways down
right
um it's it's also I could actually throw
myself off of here and then you think
well why the hell would I do that that's
stupid and then you think yeah but I
still could that's being aware of your
your possibilities not all possibilities
are good possibilities and I'll tell you
that happens to me even when I play
Minecraft and I look down over a a deep
area I have that physical reaction now
do you does that happen to you uh yes
and I I've heard people refer to this as
the call to the void
um and and I get it a lot when I drive
mountain roads with very strong oh I it
would only take me turning the uh
steering wheel like 10 degrees Yeah and
it would mean my almost certain death
and and there's like you just you're
looking at all of your possibilities and
it's like oh it's so simple and I could
just not be here yeah and and there
there is a little bit of like
pull it's like oh that is one of my
possibilities at any point in time I can
make that decision
you know and you could say this about
relationships too you could have a
relationship that we don't have to
idealize oh it's a beautiful wonderful
relationship nothing ever goes wrong
listen no it's a real life relationship
and let's say you're actually like in an
argument you know before you say that
stupid mean-biting thing that you could
say it or not say it right and now a lot
of times we do say it and then you know
what do we do immediately afterwards you
made me say that right that would be bad
faith right
this earlier you said uh you couldn't do
something because you have
responsibilities and yeah a certain
extent I believe the existentials to say
that's living in a bad faith that just
because you have that's where I think
we've reached the limits of the
existentials because they also do want
to say you should be a you should be a
decent person
and so I think with sart it's really
hard to reconcile these things and you
look at his his characters who are
heroes like uh the guy in the in the
book the book The Age of Reason the
first of his his Paths of Liberty
um uh series who's basically Sarge
himself
um he evades responsibility and it seems
almost like sart is endorsing that de
bouvoir does
and that's that's one place where I
think she differs considerably from from
sart
um and and some of the other
existentialists resisted that as well
and criticized sart for that so you know
Camus broke with with sart you know
um and and it wasn't just over communism
I think it was also over stuff like that
Gabriel Marcel criticized cert for the
first stuff like that that's why the
ethics of ambiguity is such a
unnecessary extension to I think starch
thought how do you actually yeah create
some ethics there what do you make of
that book
it's
I really like it yeah I I do too the uh
it's kind of like
she takes and has a lot of categories of
people that are very similar and remind
me of Nietzsche in his
um what is it the the Underman the uh oh
in thus books oh no sorry yeah and um
sorry the the cow The Lion and the child
and and but extends it on because like
she says yeah you can get to the place
where you're you're going around and
you're being the child that uh Nietzsche
talks about this person that is like uh
realizes that there's no intrinsic
meaning in the world that you know total
nihilist and he just goes around and
does whatever he wants to he goes and
creates a uh a project and he goes and
tries to complete it and uh Simone goes
well
but there's only certain there are
certain things that can't be done unless
you have other free people around with
you yeah and thus gets your imperative
to actually try to make more people free
right there is yeah
certain things that we need in order to
be free and if you're stuck in constant
poverty and you're being constantly
oppressed then it's going to be really
hard for you to be free yeah that is one
place where I think she definitely
improved upon starts work and it's
interesting I mean being in nothingness
that is a nutcracker of a book it's so
thick that you could crack walnuts with
it
effects of ambiguity is is like
one-fifth its length but I would say
it's there's probably as much contained
in it in terms of understanding The
Human Condition
um and yeah she she catches on to
something else that start kind of Misses
out on sart seems to be willing to say
okay everybody's got Factory everybody's
got their their challenges and places
that they begin with but you're
radically free so don't blame anybody
else for anything you know we're all
kind of radically free to the same
amount and Deborah says no way buddy
some people
are not radically free and why it's not
because they there's something wrong
with them like organically it's because
of the social conditions that they're in
they are their Factory is limited
exactly and it's limited because of the
way Society is set up and and you know
coming back to the theme of Education I
think education
plays a really important role in helping
people see that they're all there are
alternative possibilities but education
isn't enough right we we also need to
change social conditions
um you know prime example of this is
there's still a even for the the as far
as we can tell for the the Millennials
and maybe even for Generation Z there
still seems to be a gap when it comes to
domestic duties in couples
um women do more of the stuff than men
do even when they're uh uh being fully
deployed yeah yeah and and now that that
restricts facticity and very important
ways
um and I think that's something that
that you know dubuvoir would say we need
to work towards
changing that not not that we need to
say well everybody has to do exactly the
same amount of work I think she'd say
that's the sort of thing people have to
kind of
figure out negotiate with each other as
free agents responsible for themselves
trying to build something new
responsible for if they have kids other
lives and even if they have dogs or cats
um
we almost touched on last week is uh but
didn't quite get to was uh the freedom
from and the freedom too oh distinction
yeah yeah uh we often talk about that as
negative and positive Freedom right
and so I guess the I
the freedom from which would be like
you're you're free from other people's
like imposing negative things upon you
like someone you're free from someone
punching you in the face okay uh yeah
but you're uh but we don't always have
the freedom to do certain things if we
want to I don't know uh
go and go to I know India and spend
years at a monastery uh you have to have
a certain amount of material wealth in
order to pay for that
um and everyone has those those things I
would be I would be willing to say you
probably need even a certain amount of
wealth just to be able to consider that
as something that you would do right
there's so many things you know that
that's that's actually a great Point
um there's so many things that the
mentality of poverty imposes on people
it can't plan for the long term you know
or just being in in massive debt which
is the case for so many people in our
our country right now
uh What uh
like I think the statistic is like half
of the population can't deal with a
unexpected 500 bill that's right yeah
and and I think if I remember right
student loan debt just that debt not
medical debt not uh uh credit card debt
or stuff like that student loan debt is
something like if I remember correctly
again something like 1.5 trillion
dollars
you know it's a giant chunk and it's
it's you know we we see this manifest in
you know young people extending the time
in which they will marry start families
buy houses right yeah
yeah it's it it is reducing someone's
freedom to do many things that they
might have not done it's like would you
take that job at Wall Street or are you
going to take that job doing something
that you might find actually more
fulfilling because you have to pay off
your you know 150 000 in college tuition
fees yeah I mean if you could get the
job on Wall Street that that's pretty
good I think for for most people it's
you know substantially lower
offers that they're they're getting
which might not pay for this the well I
was thinking about like one that would
pay lower but actually have more
meanings them so for example I worked in
the banking industry for a while and I
hated it because I felt like it was
destroying my soul
that's um
uh just I I feel
um every day I was working in the back
end of mortgages
and so I nothing I was doing was
productive it was always destructive and
and to have your meaning be
um basically I'm a cog in the machine
that eventually results in
um
a person having one of the worst days of
their lives is really grading on one
psyche oh yeah I I worked very briefly
as a mortgage clerk at a place that
closed because interest rates changed
quickly and I hated it uh it was it was
it was awful it was right out of college
and I was temping and what we all all we
did the whole company was bundling
together mortgages into these giant
packages that investors would buy you
know and I understood what we were doing
but it it it was totally meaningless to
me you know
and in the end it was actually very
destructive
yeah I assume this was pre 2008.
this was back this would have been in
1994. wow and I remembered so I'm going
to tell the very short story I remember
um when the FED I don't know exactly
what I did with interest rates but it
did something it moved and the company
basically had to fold because they were
operating so close to the margins and
they called us in for a meeting and they
were like listen everybody we're gonna
have to send all of you home uh you know
this is this is unfortunate etc etc and
I raised my hand and I said well how
does this affect me and they're like
that doesn't affect you at all your
attempt doesn't matter you know shut up
and sit down
you know now when I thought about it I
was like yeah actually I shouldn't ask
that question because these other people
the meaning of their existence is kind
of tied up in this hell I'll find
another job you know I'm just some
schmoe who's who's uh right out of
college
um and so yeah it was kind of an
interesting thing to see happen
um sort of writing on the wall about you
know how many other places to be closing
right so I think we should move on to
our practice because yeah time here so
we've already been kind of circling
around this whole idea the entire time
it is how to live it not to live in bad
faith and uh it requires your decision
all right
sorry a second it requires a decision
yes and you have to be aware of your
practicity and you also need to be aware
of your Transcendence your your uh
set of possibilities and to actively
make choices and to I guess actively be
aware of the choices that you've already
made and that you think are restricting
yourself
yeah so how how would one do this in
very practical ways you could think of
how you define yourself and your sort of
knee-jerk reactions of thinking I am
just this or this is just this and
realize well actually I've got a choice
here I can go this way I can go this way
and and it's not going to radically
change my life most of the time but I
have that little bit of leeway now that
might produce some anxiety
yeah so for example if you're if you say
like Oh I'm a Democrat or I'm a
Republican and then someone from your
party makes a position oh that you don't
agree with and then you need to decide
if your factory as one of the person
that's part of this party overrides what
you actually think is the right thing
for you to do in this you know question
whatever it happens to be you know
that's a really great example I would
love to see
people belonging to groups like that
policing their own as we'd say like
calling them out you know saying this
isn't okay just because you know you're
you're in our our camp
another uh good example of this kind of
from a
uh outside way of looking at it is it's
like a haiku which is a poem that is has
strong restrictions within it and so it
has a factory it has to have a certain
lines and certain syllables but you do
have a large amount of artistic ability
within that very structured and tight
restrictions
do you think it's it's good for us to
have something like that where we do
have
we could call them white tight
restrictions clear clear lines and then
we we decide you know what we're going
to do the thing about relationships for
example you know should we should we say
well we don't want everything to be up
for grabs and up for negotiation all the
time we need to have like sort of you
know
um
thanks you know having ground rules that
you might lose
revisit every once in a blue moon is
probably a good idea but yeah there's
definitely especially if you go into a
marriage or something you're gonna have
some ground rules what was expected and
what is not like what can't you do and
um yeah you you have to know what also
the consequences of you breaking those
things like you know that if you're in a
relationship and you're in a monogamous
relationship that going around and
seeing other people is not going to go
and fly
that's a that's a great example I think
a lot of marriages should be benefited
by looking less at the Laos which
happened once at establishing grounds so
that's that's where we maybe will close
if you want to lead us out on some final
thoughts yeah just a nice little quote
from John Paul Sartre which are we are
condemned to be free
[Music]
um
foreign